Our final look at what is the disease concerns,
how diseases have changed over time.
The diseases encountered by our ancestors are not the diseases that we encounter
today.
Okay.
Monogenic and a stochastic developmental diseases,
however,
are nearly independent of the environment and so their frequency was probably
the same for the Greeks,
the Romans and the Han Chinese as it is for us today.
However,
environmental diseases are often caused now by mismatches between biology and
culture,
and that's a new development
we defined disease prevalence is the fraction of the population that is
afflicted.
We defined disease incidence is the number of new cases per unit time and both
prevalence and incidents very widely in space and time.
Yeah,
diseases may occur in clusters for simple reasons,
including poor nutrition or medical care and other cases.
The positive or negative correlation of diseases can have biological reasons
reflecting their genetic and physiological tradeoffs that are causing
vulnerabilities.
Monogenic and stochastic developmental diseases are important,
but there incidents is independent of the environment except for mutagenic
activity.
So exposure to ultraviolet light,
radioactivity and chemical mutagens can alter their incidents,
but if those are held constant,
then these are occurring at a fairly steady background rate.
The rare mutations that caused them are basically set by the rate at which DNA
gets repaired and buy these sort of background exposures.
Things like cosmic ray incidents.
Okay.
Their prevalence,
however,
is increasing his medical care improves.
Yeah.
That will eventually increase the frequencies in the population of some of the
mutations that caused them.
However,
it is unlikely that they will ever become very frequent.
Environmental changes are causing much bigger changes in the nature of disease.
Okay.
The major environmental changes in our history include our exit from Africa,
which exposed us to lower temperatures and new pathogens.
The agricultural revolution,
which brought with it a new diet,
urbanization and diseases that we acquired from domestic animals and the
industrial revolution,
which brought with it hygiene,
clean water,
electricity,
artificial light,
processed food and pharmaceuticals,
the form of antibiotics,
vaccines,
statins,
histamine blockers,
Nsa ids and so forth.
So we have recently experienced major environmental change on a number of
timescales.
Yeah,
no,
that mismatch.
And the outcome of mismatch depends on trade offs.
Some new diseases emerge directly from novel toxins or pathogens such as dioxin
poisoning or HIV.
Now they can be eliminated by removing the toxin or if possible,
developing a vaccine.
Others become more prevalent when environmental change shifts the cost benefit
relationship in a trade off that had been optimized to a prior environment.
For example,
immune responses that were selected in past epidemics may increase the risk of
autoimmune diseases.
Allergies and asthma.
Yeah.
Changes in the cost benefit.
Balance of trade offs are also responsible for many of the diseases.
Diseases of homeostasis such as type two diabetes and cardiovascular disease.
Environmental change is also shifting our demographics with very far reaching
consequences.
Modernity has brought a dramatic decline in extrinsic mortality had previously
been caused by childhood infections and starvation.
The resulting extension of lifespan has exposed many age related chronic
diseases that were previously rare but are now increasingly common.
Okay.
These diseases include cancer,
neurodegeneration diseases have failed defenses,
all of which are associated with age related declines in maintenance programs.
Yeah.
If these diseases are conquered,
new ones will emerge.
As the process continues,
how much average human life will be extended and how much will be will be
improved is at this point,
unclear.
Yeah.
To summarize,
the prevalence and the incidence of types of disease has been changing
dramatically,
especially recently.
Genetic and stochastic developmental diseases are relatively unaffected by
environmental change.
Environmental Change does cause most shifts in human disease patterns either
directly when environmental toxins or obesogenic diets are emerging.
Pathogens encounter us or indirectly through disruptions of tradeoff
equilibrium,
so that would elicit diseases of defenses,
homeostasis and have reduced maintenance.
The overall picture is that dramatic.
Recent environmental change is exposing vulnerabilities and trade offs in our
biology.
That evolution has not yet had time to fix.